oui bonsoir et nous jouons sans
surprise bouffer c'est massimo gargia
c'est elle que je préférais à la ferme
j'étais amoureux d'elle ouais et un jour
il m'a dit je les regrette pas je suis
très amoureuse de confiance et voilà
ces jours ci les détruire son tir 16e
vous avez quand même
oui j'étais fou d'amour pour lui elle a
dit elle a dit que ça ne choquait pas
beaucoup elle a dit c'est comme si mon
grand père m'avait touché le cul
c'est ça que tu as dis non c'est pas par
rapport à l'âge c'est plus par rapport à
la relation qu'on avait j'aimais
beaucoup massimo j'aime toujours
énormément voilà et qu'est ce que tu
m'as envoyé jeudi elles vont à un livre
un disque vous vous préférez compris
d'impressionner qu'on dise du mal du
disque d'abord ou du livre d'abord à
régler on peut dire du mal julie fils
que je suis pas écrivain majors du
disque c'est
très bien on
va commencer on a commencé avec le vivre
comme ça ce sera réglé c'est une
autobiographie vous faites votre
première autobiographie à 24 ans ouais
ça veut dire qu'il y aura une suite où
vous allez mourir bientôt non merci j'ai
font une molaire non non c'est plus que
j'avais vraiment envie de faire ce livre
depuis un petit moment parce que bon
même si j'ai 24 ans j'ai vécu quelques
déboires dans le métier de la chanson
notamment avec mon ancienne maison de
disques donc je voulais faire ce livre
mais c'est vrai que la ferme a permis de
le réaliser parce que personne nous est
forcément confiance avant sur un livre
alors ça s'appelle ma revanche mon
innocence
[Rires]
ma revanche mon innocence et si publié
city éditions c'est du ceva la 4c qui à
16 pages de photos couleur cette page
dans le livre
se lit vite française et la préface et
lui lance franck dubosc qui s'appelle ma
revanche pour l'innocence alors la
revanche c'est pour ceux qui usent se
sont moqués de vous à l'époque de la
ferme ou pour votre ancienne maison de
disques enfin c'est ça un petit peu mais
c'est vrai que c'est un petit peu tout
dans livre je détaille un peu chaque
période il ya eu plein pas il ya eu mon
adolescence c'est un petit peu plus
léger mais j'ai pris une revanche sur
tous mes camarades qui se moquaient de
moi qui disais que j'étais maigre que
j'arriverai à rien plus tard j'ai prend
une revanche sur ma maison disque avec
qui ça s'est pas toujours bien passé que
j'ai dû quitter ça a été très bon
complément de contrat et la ferme
évidemment que j'ai pris ma revanche
parce que personne misé sur moi parce
que c'est vrai ça c'est moi évidemment
le chiendent finale 1re fille donc voila
quoi alors ça c'est la revanche dans
l'innocence c'est à cause des photos à
poil dans fhm c'est ça non ah non ça
c'est pas d'innocence et c'est plus une
envie j'avais des l'innocence et plus ce
qui ressort dans la bouche des gens
quand ils parlent de moi les lettres que
je reçois en question du sort de leur
bouche un
[Rires]
trait de caractère ce qu'est ce que tu
ne sais pas jean marie c'est que elle a
été étranglée par son cordon ombilical à
une succession de son angoisse en
angoisse et romancier
je pense qu'on peut dire que ce faux
viviane lancé daniel 7 tremblements
prima m'étouffer gens ne pas être
enfermé et je pense c'est vrai que ça ça
doit moi je pense que la manière dont
temps mais avoir des conséquences sur la
manière dont on vit ce dont on est sûr
j'y croyais avant d'y aller vous
racontez votre enfance donc votre
volonté d'être un être un garçon parce
que c'est vrai quand vous étiez petit
vous exigiez de votre maman qu'elle nous
appelle simon voilà donc
c'est dans le bouquin où aucune vocation
de chanteuses aussi c'est dès l'âge de 3
ans elle chantera cap nevers a bon
dos et melun
[Applaudissements]
vous chantez quoi capella g10 et ouvrait
toutes les chansons je chantais à la
ferme plein plein de chansons du foot us
lalanne du franc suisse
bieber et laval à faure a failli au
cinéma j'adore salle laura pausini
j'adore cette chanson démission alors
allez-y allait choisir sinon c'est
tout me plaît
c'est qu'on lui toi une ont pâli maïs
est innocent comme deco mais sous djiri
square dps ty inc use in camera nouveau
mondiale et string départ raté en chine
opinons losail pointe waltraud m'arrêter
pas là la solitudine
voilà
voilà c'est ça a commencé à l'âge de
trois ans eve angeli chantait déjà ça à
l'âge de 3 ans à s'extraire vous
racontez votre premier garçon johan un
premier gars
mais c'est pas cette histoire de stylos
dans la bouche
dans la bouche c'est encore une bille de
gaming c'est à dire que j'appréhende est
tellement mon premier rendez vous
amoureux que mes copines on m'avait dit
si tu altra que tu sais pas trop comment
faire entrer deux fois sur un stylo
c'est la même chose j'avais pas compris
pour le bush
qu'il fallait mettre la langue et
j'avais pas commenter à 12 ans avec des
stylos voilà pour l'échevine est
donc la première fois que vous embrasser
un garçon c'est à l'âge de 12 ans est la
première fois que vous faites l'amour
c'est six ans plus tard c'est cette
c'est très très lent voilà avec michel
et vous n'avez jamais trompé michel donc
c'est l'amour qu'avec un seul garçon
dans votre vie à celle là c'est vrai ça
fait 17 ans et demi je voulais attendre
le bon moment je suis comme ça je suis
très perfectionniste ne voulais pas que
ça se passe avec n'importe qui ça s'est
fait avec l'homme avec qui je suis
depuis sept ans et j'espère que ce sera
le dernier lui en fait il aimait pas
tellement les femmes jeunes et pour le
séduire vous êtes déguisant vincent
mcdoom quoi tu sais ce que je dis oui
c'est vrai que j'avais mis des talents
j'avais essayé de me rendre plus femme
parce qu'en fait c'est pas qu'il aimait
pas les les femmes jeunes c'est qu'il
était sorti avec une femme jeune et
c'était la seule femme qu'il est
vraiment aimé avant moi il ça a duré
huit ans entre eux et ça c'est fini
parce que c'était son premier rhum a
elle aussi est qu'elle a voulu aller
voir ailleurs au bout de huit ans moi ça
fait sept ans j'espère j'ai pas suivi la
règle mais du coup il s'est dit plus
jamais ça et on l'espère
ne
serait
ce que par elle raconte cette histoire a
mis du temps quand même sam il avait
vraiment pas y voyait comme une gamine
quand j'avais 17 ans et demi au départ
j'étais en basket je me maquillais à
peine
été vos galères aussi pour trouver une
maison de 10 vous finissez par en
trouver une et vous dites cette chose
terrible en parlant de votre ancienne
maison 10 vous dites c'est le même
fonctionnement que les mac et les
prostituées
[Musique]
gore mais vous aviez l'impression dé sur
le trottoir vraiment
disons de ne plus faire exactement ce
que je voulais c'est plus dans ce sens
là je sens que j'ai été tenue par une
laisse voilà et dont votive à vous
raconter la ferme donc massimo gargia
qui vous met la main au cul mais
joyeusement
tout le monde était méchant contre
la détestais tous les mois est
toujours protégé au début c'est pour ça
que j'aimais beaucoup massimo c'est
qu'elle chantait qui me jugeait pas
contrairement à tous les autres qui me
porte à jugement mais j'ai toujours au
sentiment d'avoir passé une balitrand
vous tous c'est une belle tron alors
c'est une belle
et
c'est son métier c'est une des raisons
les appuis ainsi à fait maintenant des
comptes
de la sécurité sociale vous vous dites
en parlant de céline balitran son joli
sourire casse la mâchoire d'un requin et
elle vous trouve beta on peut dire la
vérité l'adie suffisamment n y pas
inventé l'eau chaude c'est ce que j'ai
pas aimé en fait c'est que c'était tout
dans le dos devant moi elle était assez
neutre bois jamais manifestés d'amour
loin des mails étaient neutres et par
derrière c'était vraiment des trucs pour
me faire battre et pour la minus que
beaucoup de gens ont cru au départ
malheureusement que j'étais à moi pas
moi
c'est la vision qu'a connue la moitié
parce que moi je sais qu est ce que tu
te libères et encore oui j'ai pas tout
si ça c'est évident mais l'aimions et
qui a volé l'orangé
aussi alors elle parle aussi de maxime
dubé maxima bateaux turcs devront
toujours pas tu rentres tu rentres pas
jouer autant les baskets tu rentres pour
parler d'accord c'est maxime réplique
c'est le genre de mec vous dites c'est
le genre de mec qui fait horreur au
format maximum mon nom c'est l'équipe et
a certainement mon nom pour moi c'est le
mec qui sort aux femmes parce que il est
vulgaire ils respectent pas les femmes
parlant du 10 est-ce que tu connais sa
carrière déjà
donc unique oui c'est indéniablement
engagé comme
11e de quoi de france
sans déconner non plus ses bras et à une
jolie mais voilà après il faut que
peut-être que tu bosses sur
exactement ça c'est alors là là dessus
on n'a pas nous venons alors là je
n'aime pas
comme ça le meilleur devant jay lee ah
oui mais c'est simple et le meilleur
jusqu'au problème
mais bon maintenant dans le show
business il vous causent meilleur
maintenant vous avez fait la ferme et
tout ça non bah disons que je me rends
pas trop compte parce que je suis je
traîne pas vraiment à paris puisque
j'habite en province je croise des gens
qui savaient plateaux télé mais c'est
pas pareil que si je les connais c'est
mieux donc ce n'est pas du tout ce qu'on
pense de moi dans mon métier mais bon
comme c'est que c'est un coup comme ça
un coup comme ça qu'on vous a dans un
coin vous déteste alors dans le vivier
un truc est très marrant c'est vos
phrases cultes relevé par emmanuel de
brantes sous le nom d' évangélisme comme
les gauchistes comme et bushisme
exactement oui alors ces appels j'ai dit
j'ai pas dis
[Musique]
alors bel et bien si vous l'avez dit ou
pas quelqu'un a essayé de traire la
poule ou pas non ça c'est pas moi qui
l'ait dit non c'est une truie c'est une
truie c'est une tondeuse quoi ah ça je
les dis parce qu'en fait je veux dire
que j'ai beaucoup de bébés c'est tout il
est monté comme un âne cette ann ée
paillis et pas de vous sait et le dit
c'est vrai que tu es miss france gall
maintenant
non mais sérieux c'est pas le brad pitt
du cheval ce cheval ça fait de moi
j'ai la chatte qui le démange c'est
normal non c'est pas moi dit elle ce
n'est pas de moi ont foutu et entre brun
et blanc donc tu hébron ces deux lois
c'est qui ce gros monsieur qui font rien
de toutes ces journées non j'ai pas dit
ça
mais j'ai pas dit ça la moitié du
dictionnaire c'est des mots pour les
vieux je n'ai pas d'imagés avec
l'évangélisme ça rentre dans le
dictionnaire
on est un peu dans le trou du cul du
monde mais j'aime ça ça c'est moi
j'écris au spectacle que vous voulez des
fois autant piché dans un tonneau oui
c'est moi ça je
préfère être vivante et en bonne santé
que vivante est malade
s'arrêter et 3 mais c'est pas moi
c'est moi pourquoi je le cerveau monté à
l'envers des fois ça fait moi c'est beau
traçabilité repris ouais j'ai une amie
qui est décédé mais pas de son plein gré
c'était c'est la fra j'aimerais revoir
le montage global un jour dans ma vie
parce que je comprends pas comment j'ai
pu lire cette conne mais bien j'en ai
une ne pas avoir de micros ne te protège
pas d'être filmé
mais pareil je devais d'ordre est assez
bon ton corps et âme ans et jean claude
van damme
elle a une haute de vous que j'adore
c'est avoir une culotte ne protège pas
de se faire baiser affaire pas moi
malheureusement
non c'est cette absence blood on
soupçonne plus bête que si j'étais brune
ça c'est vrai ça ça me manque c'est vrai
ce qu'on prend beaucoup moins de choses
maintenant pardon blonde je comprends
pas
on dirait que la barre qu'elle flotte
américaine
ces croyants le crbm c'est un beau
bouquet
final c'est l'everest
au c quoi cette grosse chose dans ton
pantalon
j'aurais pu le dire non ne sais pas moi
c'est sûr ça certains pépins qu'est ce
que tu fais chez les vaches tu n'es pas
une vache ça c'est moi
on y est
exceptionnelle et hors contexte
tu as vu la vache et la 6e'
[Applaudissements]
dis toi que le ciel est en bas avec nos
nez au dessus
à ce jour rien
et que nous on aime et je t attends
gagne c'est formidable on apprécie
[Applaudissements]
elle est l'incarnation de mélanie mois
bien sûr je mange arrive qu'à réfléchir
aux toilettes
chez vous ça
soit beau et vous hein ça pour elle mais
c'est pas malheureusement je ne ronfle
pas je me réveillerai moi-même passé moi
est ce que je me suis demandé les gens
qui ronfle comment ils font pour arriver
à dormir
syfy siffler
non mais j'ai dit aux copains tarifs les
sept nains dit je sais pas je dormais on
se demande quand ils arrivent à dormir
il est vrai qu'ils font la vie c'est
court et pourtant une heure avec toi
c'est long
c'est très beau mais c'est trop
politique
forcément je vais me laver les dents
parce que j'ai trop faim au moins ça
m'évitera de manger
parce que
le fumier fume oui ça cdc moi d'avoir
côtoyé et kaka si longtemps ça m'a donné
des idées
[Rires]
une vache c'est beau mais pas de
derrière ses alliés parce qu'un chien au
moment où je passais dans quatre ou cinq
millions de têtes nord quand ces groupes
ont un truc quand vous passez derrière
c'est vraiment un beau le meilleur des
peignes c'est les doigts oui c'est vrai
et c'est vraiment vrai pas c'est moi qui
ai dicté par la femelle du mouton c'est
la brebis à parce qu'ils se ressemblent
quand même un
oui c'est vrai c'est du pierre dac c'est
ça fait bien d'accéder un chapeau c'est
bien mais des chaussures c'est mieux
pour marcher ailleurs camille jean r mon
rôle ça va être de réfléchir à voix
basse dans ma tête oui parce que prévu
c'est que je parle trop sans l'effet de
teint sans réfléchir sans vous dis que
je pense est en deçà c'est pas le triste
tout ça et c'est pour ça que vous
fassiez procès immédiat c'est tout mais
c'est vachement bien en même temps il ya
des choses qui sont très intéressants
jean-marie si je suis subjugué
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous y mettez un
peu de bleu